good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
last week last monday we told you that
the biden administration's largest
intelligence gathering agency the nsa
had been reading my private emails even
saying that out loud is weird it's one
of those segments we never thought we
would do
ever but the country has changed that
much that fast and honestly the whole
thing was kind of shocking
the government was spying on us come on
it seemed crazy
but it's true and no one in washington
appeared to be shocked in the slightest
in fact the usual shills right after our
segment had a ready explanation for it
either it never happened at all they
said just a cable news show lying for
ratings
or there must have been a good reason it
happened and they began
furiously making excuses for the nsa did
it a powerful heavily politicized spy
agency surveilling journalists who've
been critical of the regime
no problem it's perfectly normal just
don't call it spying
but it's not normal at all it is third
world
and as we told you repeatedly it did
happen now that has been confirmed
yesterday we learned that sources in the
so-called intelligence community told at
least one reporter in washington
what was in those emails my emails
there's nothing scandalous in there
thank god we're happy to report that
late this spring i contacted a couple of
people i thought could help get us an
interview with russian president
vladimir putin
i told nobody i was doing this other
than my executive producer justin wells
i wasn't embarrassed about trying to
interview putin he's obviously
newsworthy i'm an american citizen i can
interview
anyone i want and i plan to but still in
this case i decided to keep it quiet i
figured that any kind of publicity would
rattle the russians
and make the interview less likely to
happen but the bide administration found
out anyway
by reading my emails i learned from a
whistleblower the nsa
plan to leak the contents of those
emails to media outlets
why would they do that well the point of
course was to paint me as a disloyal
american
a russian operative been called that
before a stooge of the kremlin a traitor
doing the bidding of a foreign adversary
of course i mean hardly the only person
who's been accused of those things in
the last several years
we've seen this movie several times now
at the same moment the communist chinese
government
increases its already stunning level of
control over this country
our leaders prattle on about the threat
of vladimir putin
he's an evil doer they tell us a
totalitarian dictator
vladimir putin does things that no
american leader would even consider
he runs domestic disinformation
campaigns he lies to the public
he punishes people for opposing him or
for believing the wrong things
he even uses intelligence agencies to
spy on his own citizens
beyond the pale stuff so no decent
american would interview vladimir putin
at least no reporter from fox news
that was the point they wanted to make
that's why they plan to leak the
contents
of my emails to news organizations and
yesterday as noted
we learned they actually did it even now
some of the media are claiming that we
deserve this
emailing with people who know putin are
you of course the nsa is watching you
that's what you get
but that's hardly the point by law the
nsa is required to keep secret the
identities of american citizens who've
been caught up in its vast domestic
spying operations
so by law i should have been identified
internally
merely as a u.s journalist or american
journalist that's the law
but that's not how i was identified it
was identified by name i was
unmasked people in the building learned
who i was
and then my name and the contents of my
emails left that building at the nsa and
wound up with a news organization in
washington
that is illegal in fact it is precisely
what this law was designed to prevent
in the first place we cannot have
intelligence agencies used as
instruments of political control
both parties used to agree on that
democrats were especially adamant on the
point
but not anymore so that's exactly what
is happening
here we need to find out how this
happened who did it
who allowed it paul nakasoni would know
the answer paul nakasoni is the highly
political director of the nsa
paul nakasoni would have been required
personally to improve approve
my unmasking that's how it works paul
nakasoni should explain
who asked for that unmasking and he
should do it immediately
avril haynes would also likely know the
answer hanes is the even more political
director of the
of national intelligence she oversees
all of it she may have approved the
unmasking as well she would certainly
know
who asked for it and who approved it
that's her job to know
she should release that information
immediately tonight
and if april haynes does not release an
information she should be forced
to release that information we don't
have a lot of powers to tv show but
we're going to keep pushing for that
because it matters not just to us but to
the entire country you can't have a
democracy
in a place where unaccountable spy
agencies
keep people in line by leaking the
contents of their emails discrediting
them
with their own emails which they thought
were private you can't it doesn't work
if you allow that and we suspect
congressional republicans
will also demand an answer many have
finally awakened to the fact that the
intelligence agencies which they have
blindly supported for so long
are not in fact their friends they're
not the friends of anyone in this
country they're dangerous
that's obvious hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else